[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans votre cette fuite week-end nous
allons parler actualités mais aussi
loisirs
voici les titres de ce vendredi 12 mars
retour sur le déplacement de julien
bayou tête de la liste l'écologie
évidemment jeudi 11 mars à trappes
il fait campagne pour les élections
régionales d'île de france 2 juin
prochain avec une liste de rassemblement
l'ancien candidat à la présidentielle
benoît hamon en fait d'ailleurs partie
est notre invité cette semaine laurent
bros maire de conflans-sainte-honorine
nous parlerons du plan de lutte et de
prévention contre le harcèlement
scolaire que sa ville a mis en place
enfin comme chaque semaine c'est les
agat son go vous proposera à ses idées
sorties et loisirs pour le week end
[Applaudissements]
comme je vous le disais en titre julien
bayou tête de la liste l'écologie
évidemment étaient présents jeudi 11
mars à trappes
le candidat fait campagne sur le terrain
pour les élections régionales qui sont
prévues en juin 2021 sa liste représente
le rassemblement de la ligne politique
écologiste et solidaire autour notamment
de l'ancien socialiste benoît hamon
les détails de bixente mais rien senti
stéphane et nicolas landry une visite
sur le thème de la mobilité et de la
restauration scolaire
l'objet du déplacement à trappes de
julien bayou cette commune
un véritable laboratoire pour la
politique écologiste et sociale voulue
par la liste l'écologie évidemment je
retiens évidemment l'enjeu de
démocratiser l'écologie faire de deux
trappes et de la région et de france
le phare de la transition écologique
notamment l'écologie populaire et parce
que les quartiers populaires les classes
populaires les classes moyennes sont les
premières bénéficiaires bénéficiaires de
l'action écologique
on le voit avec la cantine scolaire ça
permet à chaque enfant d'avoir un vrai
repas équilibrés cette liste rassemble
plusieurs mouvements politiques de
gauche
parmi eux génération point s créé par
benoît hamon candidat socialiste à
l'élection présidentielle de 2017
l'ancien député de la 11e
circonscription des yvelines a quitté le
ps après ce recul avec la politique il
est candidat dans la liste de julien
bayou là on a un rassemblement vraiment
bilingue qui est capable de parler
d'écologie transition écologique mais
aussi de penser les impacts en termes de
justice sociale qui ne fait pas en étant
en considérant que le développement
économique c'est pas une bonne chose au
contraire en essayant de penser la
cohérence de ces choix là dans les
yvelines la candidature l'écologie
évidemment est porté par ghislaine ce
n'est conseil régional depuis 2010 elle
se lance dans sa troisième campagne en
ile de france
il va y avoir la la la révision du
schéma directeur de la région
ile-de-france un schéma d'aménagement
ça peut se faire qu'en concertation et
avec les maires et avec la population
parce que pour assumer et pour
réellement porter cette transition
écologique il faut que tous les acteurs
soient soient soient partants
les franciliens sont appelés aux urnes
le dimanche 13 juin 2021 pour élire les
209 futurs conseillers régionaux d'île
de france
nous allons à présent parler d'un fléau
qui est malheureusement toujours
qualité le harcèlement scolaire 10% des
élèves de primaire 6% des collégiens ou
encore 1,4 pour cent des lycéens
subissent un harcèlement scolaire en
france cela représente environ 700 mille
victimes par an qui conduit parfois à
des drames ça a été le cas la semaine
dernière à argenteuil en
seine-saint-denis où une adolescente de
14 ans a été tué par deux de ses
camarades après avoir été harcelés pour
parler de ce sujet et nous accueillons
en visioconférence avec nous laurent
bros bonsoir bonsoir c'est ok vous êtes
donc le maire de conflans sainte
honorine et la ville a mis en place un
plan de lutte et de prévention contre le
harcèlement scolaire en partenariat avec
l'éducation nationale avant de le
détailler cette mise en place de ce plan
de lutte et de prévention fait suite
justement à des cas de harcèlement
scolaire que vous avez détecté dans vos
établissements de votre commune depuis
ces dernières années
que s'est il passé et comment vous les
avez repéré alors en fait l'origine
c'est une parents d'élèves qui m'a
alerté sur sur le cas de son enfant qui
est suivi cds des brimades et plus
globalement de faits de harcèlement
scolaire la cour de récréation et donc à
cette occasion elle m'a dit qu'elle se
trouvait des mini par rapport à cette
situation et elle a valorisé le fait qu'
il fallait semblait nécessaire de faire
et donc dans ce cadre je lui proposais
de notre en place et donc à conflans
sainte honorine compte ces écoles
élémentaires du cp au cm2 je le rappelle
2000 enfants au total ce plan de lutte
et de prévention
et justement à destination finalement
deux de ces écoles élémentaires en quoi
consiste-t-il concrètement qu'est-ce que
vous avez mis en place dans ce plan
concrètement la semaine articulé autour
de trois axes le premier axe c'est
informer et sensibiliser le deuxième axe
c'est un axe qui est plus un axe pour
former
le troisième axe c'est prévenir et gien
sur le premier axe c'est à dire sur
l'information la sensibilisation c'est
plutôt un axe de communication qui vise
à informer les parents l'éducation
nationale qu'elle est bel et professeurs
sur les différentes formes de
harcèlement sur les moyens de repérer
ces situations le deuxième axe fort mais
là c'est un axe comme son indic de
formation c'est à dire que l'objectif de
la ville de conflans sainte honorine
c'est de former nos animateurs qui
travailleront plus près des enfants
pendant le temps périscolaire donc
pendant les temps de bahts 1 du midi du
soir et pendant les temps de centres de
loisirs le mercredi et donc on a lancé
un plan pour que nous puissions former
nos animateurs ce sont 24 animateurs qui
ont été formés l'année dernière à
conflans sainte honorine en lien avec le
harcèlement scolaire et le troisième axe
c'est prévenir et agir et donc là c'est
un travail que nous poursuivons un des
rares éducation nationale et plus
globalement d'autres partenaires non
pour l'unicef et donc l'idée c'est que
nous ayons des actions concrètes dans
les écoles ou s'effacer notamment or une
semaine pendant l'année qui dédiez voir
scène scolaire et donc des enfants qui
qui réalise notamment le mur
d'expression ça c'est pour les enfants
de ce2 cm2 qui vise en fait à alors
faire des dessins des illustrations sur
le harcèlement pour mieux leur expliquer
ce dont il s'agit est au c ur de parole
qui existe au sein des au sein des
écoles pour libérer en quelque sorte la
parole des enfants sur ce sujet là et
puis il ya aussi des actions directes
dans les dents les épaules à petit sur
les réseaux sociaux puisque se développe
beaucoup c'est naze année le cyber
harcèlement et donc on a souhaité aussi
quelque part sensibiliser les enfants
sur l'utilisation des réseaux sociaux
problématique qui est de plus en plus
élevés avec un harcèlement scolaire qui
devient non plus
harcèlement unique dans l'enceinte de
l'école mais un
seulement 24 heures sur 24 et 7 jours
sur 7 avec les nouveaux moyens de
communication
il me sert bien non justement dans un
instant juste avant cela donc le plan de
prévention et de lutte contre le
harcèlement scolaire que vous avez mis
en place c'est uniquement pour les
écoles élémentaires pour le moment et
vous le voulez l'étendre au collège et
au lycée
qu'en est il quand est ce que ce sera
étendue est ce que vous avez toujours ce
projet de l'étendre où il pousse que
j'avais le projet est toujours de
d'étendre ce dispositif au collège et au
lycée
en réalité je suis en pleine
concertation en ce moment avec
l'éducation nationale avec l'association
sportive également sur le plan d'action
pour la jeunesse et la citoyenneté est
donc ce plan inclut un volet de lutte
contre la sers dans scolaire dans les
collèges et les lycées
c'est un plan que devrait présenter
d'ici le mois de mai au plus tard donc
si plus que jamais d'actualité
vous l'avez évoqué donc juste avant hier
le versement au sein même de l'école
mais aujourd'hui aussi on voit ce
nouveau phénomène avec internet ce cyber
harcèlement et ça peut être un phénomène
aggravant le fait d'être harcelée sur
internet
en plus d'être harcelé à l'école cela
continue donc du coup pour les enfants
même en rentrant à la maison pour vous
ces réseaux sociaux fait ce que
finalement c'est quand même peut-être ça
le fond du problème plus qu'internet est
ce que ça augmente ce phénomène de
harcèlement scolaire est ce que c'est
dangereux
aussi quand tu as un enfant est harcelé
pour cet enfant ce qui est très
dangereux de ces réseaux sociaux c'est
que finalement comme jeudi à quelques
instants les faits de harcèlement
scolaire était auparavant exclusivement
dans l'enceinte de l'établissement
et donc c'était pendant un temps donné
lorsque tu veux rien mais ça permettait
quelque part à l'élève après de souffle
et de passer à autre chose
actuellement d'en parler avec sa famille
là on est sur quelque chose d' avec ce
super harcèlement qui dépasse
l'enceinte de l'établissement scolaire
et donc qu'ils se reproduisent sur sur
d'autres choses donc ce que les réseaux
sociaux c'est pat aussi par texto et
donc ça c'est quelque chose qui devient
difficilement soutenable pour les élèves
parce qu'on n'est plus seulement sur le
temps scolaire on est sur un temps qui
s'étend sur toute la journée
24 heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7 et donc
ça devient pour ces enfants victimes
d'harcèlement très difficile à gérer
psycho vie et je rappelle que quand on
est harcelé pour ce qu'ils nous
entendent et nous regardent
il faut en parler merci laurent bros
d'avoir été avec nous sur ce set 8
week-end par visioconférence et je
rappelle que vous êtes le maire de
conflans-sainte-honorine
on change de sujet à présent comme
chaque vendredi célia gars tsongo vous
propose ses idées sorties et loisirs
[Applaudissements]
cette semaine nous allons apprendre à
danser l'afro tribal ce style de danse
est pratiqué dans différents pays
d'afrique mails des pas de danses
ancestrales
les membres de l'association world step
event nous ont enseigné quelques
exercices
les images de mélanie poker
[Musique]
nous sommes à bois dans le bretonneux
avec une membre de l'association event
et chemins beaux jours à jour vous allez
nous montre un peu d'exercice d'afro
alors d'abord qu'est-ce que c'est la
frau alors oui enfin il ya la frau
qu'une voix sont les réseaux et puis à
la fraude tribal fidji tribal convient
de différencier les deux du coup c'est
des danses ancestrales qu'on fait dans
différents pays en afrique de base ont
la dent ce pieds nus cette instance
pieds nus avec les tenues
traditionnelles et tout ça on va faire
quelques exercices c'est parti donc on
va juste levé de jeu mou voilà
maintenant la tendance actuelle sera
conduit toujours plié mais j'étais chez
nous qui est très jeune fille et le
poids du corps rendant au milieu voilà
donc maintenant on va faire 1 2 3 4 et 5
6 sec
on va ça ne paraît donc là c'est juste
le pied en arrive à 2 3 4 et 5
siph sais tu as des trois cadres
d'autres côté 5 6 7 6 mappy policiers de
garder le plier et a toujours ce côté
robot l'art voilà ça seront là c'est
pour vraiment garder le rythme
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est un autre exercice que vous pouvez
me montrer wii passe aussi moi je
l'appelle la chaussette la chaussette
on enlève la chaussette alors comme ça
et on veut mais la chaussée on ne sait
toutefois pas ce que vous refait sa 6 et
sa 600 et 1 2 3 4 et 5 6 7 8 et 1 2 3 4
des 5 6 qui temps dans l'es2 la
chaussette sont remis ma chaussette
enlève la chaussette
rené vacher sait qu'elle doit beaucoup à
ses conseils cela fait quinze minutes
quand la pratique hélas trop finalement
ce sont des comptes et pas assez simple
et accessible à tous
des cours en vidéo sont donnés toutes
les semaines et toutes les informations
sont à retrouver sur leur page facebook
et sur leur faim sa g
ce jour-là un cours de danse freestyle
en visio et donner aux enfants comme aux
adultes le thème carnaval
partons à présent dans l'univers des
mangas de plus en plus de français
apprécient ces bandes dessinées
japonaises et les yvelinois ne sont pas
en reste une boutique a donc ouvert ses
portes à versailles pour permettre aux
amateurs de mangas de retrouver leur
héros sous forme de produits dérivés
avec le bij est d'aimer rien senti
steban nous avons interviewé le gérant
de la boutique
regardez
[Musique]
si vous êtes passionné d'animation
japonaise et de pop culture vous ferez
certainement un tour à manga story dans
cette boutique on peut trouver des
produits dérivés mais aussi des posters
ou des mangas enzo le garn bonjour
bonjour vous êtes le co gérant de cette
boutique alors la boutique a ouverte il
ya à peu près quatre mois est ce que les
amateurs de mangas sont au rendez vous
alors oui oui sont ils sont au rendez
vous ils sont très contents d'avoir un
lieu comme comme tel proche de chez eux
du coup ils au rendez vous depuis
maintenant web depuis maintenant quatre
mois
ils sont très contents les versailles et
son sont amateurs de mangas pourquoi
avoir finalement créé cette boutique
dans versailles
tout simplement parce que c'est quand
même vers 16 comme une ville importante
de la région avec le château juste en
face du coup et puis même verfeil c'est
pas forcément proche de paris a quand
même pas mal tout en transport du coup
c'est quand même l'occasion de que les
habitants du secteur puissent avoir un
lieu comme tel croire se retrouver à
acheter des produits de série 10 m vous
avez beaucoup de produits dérivés
ce que vous pouvez me dire combien vous
en avez à peu près quelles sont les
catégories sont produits alors pour les
catégories on va avoir un peu tôt alors
des figurines des peluches des posters
et des mugs entre autres mais on a pas
mal de choses aussi pour plus
spécialisés comme des maquettes et
maquettes des petites constructions on a
des coffrets cadeaux vraiment du tout en
rapport avec avec les mangas c'est
vraiment un peu un peu tout et d'armes
de référence on devra avoir je pense
2000 références différentes
c'était pas mal question peuvent au
produit star que vous vendez le plus
finalement après le généralement les
produits qui vont le plus attiré l'oeil
de nos clients ça va être les mangas et
les figurines du coutier représentent
leurs personnages favoris de chaque
série
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que vous pouvez peut-être me
présenter un beau coup de coeur alors
oui bien sûr alors moi comme comme
produit que personne particulièrement ça
va être ce projet là c'est une figurine
représentant le chic et le héros de du
manga one piece qui est le manga le plus
le plus populaire au monde c'est le
manga le plus vendu au monde depuis
maintenant quelques années
donc voilà c'est une figurine qui
représente le héros sous différentes
formes
il ya de nombreuses boutiques de deux
mangas qui maintenant se développe un
peu à votre avis qu'est ce qui fait que
la culture manga est de plus en plus
apprécié et populaire en france
finalement bon parce que elle est de
plus en plus accessible maintenant pour
pour tout le monde avec les plateformes
de streaming pour les animer les mangas
du coup maintenant les rayon librairie
de chaque boutique se développe à la
fnac y en a de plus en plus partout en
fait dans partout film avec netflix cas
maintenant alors je catalogue d'animer
du coup c'est beaucoup plus accessible
pour les plus jeunes comme pour les plus
vieux mais juste et moi quel type de
public qui vient dans votre un peu de
tours va avoir cinq ou dix des plus
jeunes ça peut commencer à 4 5 ans pour
des peluches ou des jouets com de com
des pères des mères de famille de 40 ans
qui souhaitent avoir des produits
représentant leurs personnages de leur
enfance pour le côté un peu nostalgique
car est ce qu'il y a aussi des mangas ou
des séries dans la guerre allemands qui
sont un peu tendance en ce moment alors
oui alors on va avoir déjà les grands
indémodable et grands classiques qui
sont qui resteront toujours au goût du
jour qui sont one piece dragon ball ou
encore naruto mais il est vrai qu'il ya
d'autres séries qui sont en train de
vraiment d'émerger même mondialement
comme actuellement la taille des tic en
damon skieurs et le dernier petit
nouveau qui est vraiment en train
d'exploser cdu dit ce qu'elle sait très
bien les bains merci beaucoup et ns
nigam d'avoir été notre invité c'est moi
qui vous remercie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et pour finir cette page loisirs je vous
propose trois idées d'activités pour ce
week end avec une exposition temporaire
en ligne nommée à la ville a habité on
peut la retrouver sur le site internet
de saint quentin en yvelines dans la
rubrique culture en ligne la visite de
l'exposition se fait en 360 degrés elle
parle de l'évolution de la politique du
logement en france à travers des
exemples de 25 opérations architectural
à saint quentin en yvelines
le festival à tout bout de champ
s'adaptent et proposent une version
numérique
dimanche 14 mars à 17h venez découvrir
la comédie musicale les grands chante
pour les petits sur youtube un spectacle
sur le thème du cirque dans lequel les
enfants rappelle que la culture est
primordiale et un autre festival en
ligne se déroule lui aussi ce week end
le festival électro chic revient pour
une cinquième édition 100% en ligne du
11 au 13 mars
au programme concert avec mot cadeaux ou
médium 12 par exemple ce vendredi à 21h
mais aussi un tremplin qui régnera cinq
groupes ou jeunes artistes qui
présenteront un titre de leur répertoire
et le public pourra voter en ligne
coup d'envoi pour le tremplin samedi 13
mars à 21h sur la page facebook où la
chaîne youtube du festival électro chic
et le 7-8 week-end se poursuit avec
eléonore pour parler de l'actualité
[Applaudissements]
et à présent l'actualité de la semaine
c'est astrid bergère qui vous la résume
en 78 secondes la course au soleil pour
bien son nom c'est sous un temps
magnifique que les coureurs se sont
élancés dimanche et lundi des yvelines à
saint cyr l'école et - ville sur mansion
depuis douze ans le département
accueille de paris-nice lundi 8 mars
c'était la journée internationale des
droits des femmes
à cette occasion la commune de ben et la
préfecture des épines ont signé une
convention pour lutter contre les
violences sexistes et sexuelles
les services municipaux seront mobilisés
auprès des associations et des services
de l'état
une semaine marquée par l'accélération
de la vaccination dans le département
après un week-end où 1700 personnes ont
été vaccinées au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
la vie reprend un peu son cours dans les
ehpad la précarité étudiante au coeur
des préoccupations dans le département
de nombreuses initiatives commencent à
se développer
l'association élan coeur a organisé une
distribution de colis alimentaires à est
en cours de son côté le conseil
départemental prévoit 1,2 million
d'euros pour venir en aide aux étudiants
gérard ramond s'est éteint à l'âge de 86
ans ce sculpteur est à l'origine de
nombreuses oeuvres présentes à maurepas
il avait aussi travaillé de pair avec
l'urbaniste et jacques riboud lors de la
construction de la ville nouvelle
[Musique]
et la semaine prochaine que va-t-il se
passer
réponse avec vous astrid bergère
journalistes de la rédaction est
responsable de l'émission vais y paie
bonsoir bonsoir
alors évidemment j'imagine qu'on va
parler quand même d un an du premier
confinement le 17 mars prochain
oui les honneurs mercredi prochain nous
serons donc le 17 mars
et rappelez vous à cette date l'année
dernière précisément à midi c'était le
début du premier confinement un
confinement soudain dur on le voit sur
ces images les rues sont vides les
français sommé de rester chez eux
la france entière s'est arrêté et ce
jusqu'au 11 mai 2020 alors pour fêter ce
triste anniversaire nous irons à la
rencontre des acteurs du sport de la
culture bien sûr du monde de l'art
est-il de la restauration pardon aussi
les entreprises et les jeunes qui
subissent toujours cette crise sanitaire
en ans plus tard mais certains ont tout
de même pu tirer leur épingle du jeu
quand même penser crise astrid oui alors
certaines entreprises ont su se
réinventer
nous ferons le point sur différentes
initiatives qui ont été mises en place
comme le déploiement des tentes qu'ovide
le recyclage des masques et autres
encore on pense évidemment à ceux qui
sont toujours éprouvé par la pandémie
comme le monde de la culture de la nuit
et de la restauration si on a su à ce
jour toujours pas de date de réouverture
merci à strip pour toutes ces précisions
et je rappelle donc que cette émission
spéciale consacrée aux un nom du premier
confinement ce sera le 17 mars prochain
à 18h en direct et pour refermer ce 7,8
week end comme chaque semaine votre
rendez-vous en partenariat avec les
surligneurs ce collectif qui décrypte
les déclarations des personnalités
publiques et politiques
aujourd'hui retour sur jean luc
mélenchon et la levée des brevets sur
les vaccins on écoute vincent couronne
fondateur des surligneurs et professeur
en droit à l'université versailles saint
quentin
jean luc mélenchon dénonce la gestion de
la production de vaccin contre le coc
vie de 19 par l'industrie pharmaceutique
et appelle à la levée des brevets sur
les vaccins l'idée selon lui est de
permettre à d'autres entreprises de
fabriquer le vaccin et mettre un terme à
l' enrichissement sans cause des
entreprises pharmaceutiques
sauf que le patron de la france
insoumise fait ici une confusion
qu'est ce qu'un brevet le brevet bien il
permet à celui qui l'a déposé freezer ou
astrazeneca par exemple d'obtenir un
monopole d'exploitation se son intention
concrètement celui qui a inventé le
vaccin est le seul à pouvoir le produire
en temps normal le brevet protège
l'inventeur et lui permet de
rentabiliser ses investissements
il favorise donc l'innovation et sans
cette protection légale
on attendrait toujours le vaccin contre
le coc vie 19 mai lorsque sont en jeu
des questions de santé publique
ce monopole peut paraître injuste voire
problématique
la loi prévoit donc ce qu'on appelle des
licences d'office
ce mécanisme permet à l'état d'obliger
les titulaires de brevets a cédé une
licence d'exploitation à d'autres
fabricants afin de satisfaire un besoin
général mais contrairement à ce que dit
jean luc mélenchon la licence d'office
n'est pas une suppression du brevet
encore moins il confie qu une
confiscation ou une nationalisation du
brevet c'est une licence d'exploitation
en échange d'une rémunération et qui
n'empêchera pas les laboratoires
pharmaceutiques de continuer à produire
et à vendre lui-même sur vaccins
c'est déjà la fin de votre 7,8 week-end
merci de l'avoir suivi l'information
revient lundi à 18h en direct dans le
7-8 journal présenté par grégory canale
et d'ici là je souhaite un très bon
week-end et une très belle soirée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
oh
[Applaudissements]
on
non
[Musique]